[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream
108 take
four this is the eight o'clock class
edition
and we are experiencing clearly it's too
early for all of us it's too early for
all of us right this is not a civilized
hour here on the west coast um i mean i
guess it's even worse if you're in
hawaii unless you're up since last night
but nonetheless um we are going to try
this and as i was explaining before the
massive technical hiccup that
accompanied apparently a deepening of
our voices i don't know what all but we
have power fluctuations today because it
is in the pacific northwest it's
december and uh what happens when those
two things come together here is that
the trees wobble and they get drenched
and they fall on power lines and
everything goes to put and we've seen
our power fluctuate multiple times this
morning and i think uh it has messed
with every system that is dependent on
constant power indeed well we're gonna
do what we can do here um we're gonna
we're gonna do a little
fast and furious here this morning we
have we have places to be that aren't
here um which is why we're coming to you
early so um without further ado we're
gonna talk about some some books we're
gonna talk a little bit a little bit
about omicron uh just you know very
various things today and uh we'll then
as usual take a break and then come back
for a uh concentrated q a maybe 45
minutes
um but first let's do logistics
shall we um a hunter gatherer's guide to
the 21st century continues to sell well
we appreciate your uh your enthusiasm
for it we continue to hear really great
things about it we have been on we
continue to be on other people's
podcasts
um talking about it the most recent one
uh being forward with andrew yang this
is a great conversation i really enjoyed
this me too uh so hopefully i will
remember to put the link to that in in
our show notes as well but we encourage
you to go to go find that starts out a
little a little meandering and slow but
i think we really get into some
important issues but you know andrew is
so darn likable and diverse and
interesting and you know you know it's
crazy i see a guy like that and i think
i mean wouldn't it be cool if you ran
for office
yeah wouldn't it wouldn't it be i mean
wouldn't that be great if we just
elected people i don't know why that
doesn't happen maybe we'll talk to him
about it yeah that would be awesome
okay um we there as we announced last
week uh there is a book bookstore on
orcas island darville's bookshop um
which can be found right here actually
show my screen just briefly zachary
darville's
bookstore.indie light i think it is dot
org
you can go there and order a signed copy
of our book if you are so interested if
i may zachary
and that link will also be in the show
notes
and presumably you could also go pick
one up in person oh absolutely yeah not
until um
uh
i think sunday afternoon is the soonest
there will be any in person though
um if you're watching on youtube we are
also of course streaming to odyssey
where the live chat is happening you can
ask questions for the q a that will
happen immediately after here at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
we have patreons which we have told you
about uh often and uh right now the
question asking period is open on my
patreon for the private q a uh that
we'll be doing a week early this month
so rather than on boxing day on december
26th we'll be doing it on december 19th
and indeed we may be taking a couple of
weeks
break from from dark horse we will not
be streaming on christmas or on new
year's day um but we might we may add in
we may add an episode in there one or
two places um and we being addicts
apparently unlikely addict of the of the
form
yeah i don't i don't think that's what's
driving it no no no
um
we appreciate how many people we hear
from who really um are finding value in
what we're doing and uh
and
and that in turn uh helps us uh know
that we are doing things of value in the
world we are honored to be your reality
check and we apologize for the reality
yes
about which we are doing everything we
can
uh we have a variety of products that
have been up for a couple of weeks at
the
store.darkhorsepodcast.org direwolves
saddle up the direwolves we ride tonight
epic tabby digital book burning a
variety of other things and um
our wonderful artist david eldred uh you
may put up my screen here for a moment
zachary
has a website now uh where he has some
of his
his work and you can contact him if you
are interested you know you will find
some some familiar artwork here right on
this site
including he also did the um did the
artwork for our book website um so he's
just he's terrific and um
and just a joy to work with and we
encourage you to go look him up yeah
he's got such an incredible what's the
visual
equivalent of a voice yeah you know yeah
it's style does not seem up to the
challenge of describing it but it's so
beautiful yeah it really is
um
and on natural selections this week my
sub stack
uh i i co-wrote this time with our
friend uh and long-time collaborator and
former student drew schneiderler
a piece on on gifting traditions in
spiders
in octopus in uh iran in the kung
in the modern world i feel like i have
to do that even though it feels
ridiculous yeah you faked that very well
um
so that was um that was really actually
a joy to write so i encourage everyone
to go there and we have three ads this
week
all right without further ado three ads
for you this week
the first is moic
m-o-i-n-k that's a uh that's like a
portmanteau of moo and oik
our first sponsor this week is moyk they
deliver grass-fed and grass-finished
beef and lamb pastured pork and chicken
and wild-caught alaskan salmon and
turkey
direct to your door just four companies
control eighty percent of the us meat
industry and moic is helping family
farms become financially independent
outside of big agriculture
i love this company that really i really
do mike sent us a turkey for
thanksgiving so since we came to you
last um
uh we have actually had their turkey as
well and seriously guys so so good yeah
it was completely off the hook i must
say it was a i'm a huge fan of turkey
yeah yeah so so are we all really good
yeah here here at uh weinstein hiring
household we all really do love turkey
and this is just terrific um and before
that
when we came to you the first time we
had already had steaks and bacon and
chicken and lamb from them we haven't
tried all of the stuff they sent us in
that first box
but everything we have tried is out of
this world so good i particularly love
the rib eye steak and the sausages were
terrific too
monk's animals are raised outdoors their
fish swim wild in the ocean and moik
meat is free of antibiotics hormones
sugar and all the other junk you find
prepackaged in so much that's what of
what is in the meat aisle
i love everything about this company the
fact that the meat is grass-fed finished
on small farms the lovely publications
that come with it this reminds me this
is this is one of them this reminds me
of what gourmet magazine was back in the
day um before it started to change and
then went belly up or got botter i don't
remember exactly what happened but it's
gone now
and of course the meat itself moich was
founded by an eighth generation farmer
which i also love support mike support
family farming
so join the mike movement today go to
moiquebox.com
right now to get a year of ground beef
for free
i always wonder with with things like
that though how they estimate how much
ground beef you eat i don't know you get
a year of ground beef for free if you go
to moinkbox.com darkhorse then pick what
meats you want delivered with your first
box change what you get each month and
cancel any time that's one year of the
best ground beef you'll ever taste but
for a limited time
spelled m-o-i-n-k-box
dot com slash darkhorse i read that
badly m-m-o-i-n-k-box.com
darkhorse that's moiquebox.com
darkhorse
all right
well we're going to switch gears a
little bit
um it's vevo barefoot
now
most shoes are not made for your feet
but here's the thing nobody ever says
they're not made for anybody's feet
right they're just made to get you from
here to there and it's not what you want
it really uh messes with your ability to
load them up
they are made for someone else's idea of
what feet should look like and do
and be constrained by and usually that
someone doesn't actually know feet or
what they can do vivo barefoot in
contrast knows feet vivobarefoot isn't
driven by fashion
you can tell because the shoes aren't
really that usual looking
but oh man are these shoes a revelation
we both think so we've both been wearing
them all over the place we love these
shoes they are beyond comfortable
tactile feedback from the surfaces you
are walking on is amazing and they cause
you no pain at all because there's no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions they're fantastic your
feet are the product of millions of
years of evolution
humans evolve to walk move and run
barefoot but modern shoes that are
overly cushioned and strangely shaped
have negatively impacted foot function
and are contributing to health crises
one in which people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet hurt vivo barefoot shoes are
designed wide to provide natural
stability thin to enable you to feel
more and flexible to help you build your
natural strength from the ground up
foot strength increases by 60 percent in
a matter of months just by walking
around in them
we both keep running into people out in
the world who comment on the
vivobarefoot shoes that we are wearing
they are wearing them too often it is an
odd little club but growing once people
start wearing these shoes they don't
seem to stop
go to
vivobarefoot.com darkhorse to get an
exclusive offer of 20 off additionally
all new customers get a hundred day free
trial so you can see if you love them as
much as we do that's vevobarefoot.com
vivo
dot com slash dark horse
and finally this episode is sponsored by
four sigmatic a wellness company known
for its delicious mushroom coffee as
well as protein powders that contain
mushrooms weird yep delicious also yes
i'm having some right now in this
beautiful mug that was handcrafted for
us by fan of darkhorse
four sigmatics mushroom coffee contains
organic fair trade single origin arabica
coffee with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms
four sigmatic ground mushroom coffee
with lion's mane adds a little something
some crispness and focus it's delicious
just like your favorite coffee dark and
nutty
and the protein powders which i did not
think i was going to be at all
interested in because in general that's
not the way i go
i find
added to a smoothie or to banana bread
for instance i made some banana bread
yesterday and added a little bit um it
punched punches up the protein a little
which is uh which is a value and
um and again gives a little something a
little christmas and focus focus
focus
focus
and doesn't change the taste but they
also have protein powders that do have a
flavor so they've got this peanut butter
protein powder which i add to smoothies
i haven't done this in a little while
but with banana honey cacao nibs cacao
nibs uh peanut butter and milk or dairy
free alternative if you like
and their peanut butter protein powder
increases not just the protein but the
peanut buttery flavor which is a good
thing if that's what you're into
all four sigmatic products are organic
vegan and gluten-free every batch is
third-party lab tested to ensure its
purity and safety and they have a
hundred percent money back guarantee
love every sip or get your money back
we've got an exclusive offer with four
sigmatic that's f o u r sigmatic on
their best selling mushroom coffee for
dark horse listeners get up to 40 off
and free shipping on mushroom coffee
bundles to claim this deal go to
4sigmatic.com
darkhorse that is f o u r s i g m a t i
c dot com dark horse fuel your
productivity and creativity with some
delicious mushroom coffee
now you said cacao nibs just indeed how
we say that but you said banana bread
and we say bonanza bread so what gives
what gives no one would know oh you want
me to add protein powder to my bonanza
bread well i've never had bonanza bread
therefore i don't need that product
that's what people would think i guess i
guess well all right maybe you made the
right call but still still
maybe if an apology isn't working
wow
if it turns out that i believe an
apology is in order to um to you the
family the bonanza bread enthusiasts
everywhere i will come back and provide
one bonanza bread industry
um there's not one of those oh
yeah
nor will i apologize to the apparently
nascent if it exists at all bonanza
bread industry big bonanza
a little bonanza yet all right
all right um
okay let's see it is wow it's already 8
30.
on the west coast
last week in our q a
we
uh were asked this question
quote i teach college english in prison
a student asked for a list of 12 books
he ought to read over winter break that
i thought were important what would your
respective answers be
and this is this is the sort of
assignment that i do actually enjoy uh
it's
it's um
it's tough of course because
what
what to render something important
and so i ended up uh
scanning our our bookshelves and really
only held myself to one standard which
was i have to have read it
i know there there are books on our
bookshelves that i know to be important
and that i've read parts of or not at
all and
none of those are on this
on this list um
many people familiar with darkhorse will
recognize um
many of these um i think i've talked
about
almost all of them at some point
and i've also on my patreon i have some
book lists i've got a list from november
20th on my patreon of 25 books that i
themed
history and resistance uh and at the
year marker of dark horse in march of
2021 i went back through and talked a
little bit about all the books i had
read from which was another 24-25
but really you know what what ended up
how things ended up on this this book is
um if it felt a little bit
apropos right now and there are
too many amazing books that didn't that
don't show up here
but
but well i have i have them here i have
this pile of 12 books and i and i will
show you but first i'm actually going to
read a little bit from a book that i
thought i was going to put on the list
but i decided not to because i didn't
think that it quite
didn't quite live up to the promise but
there's something early on that i wanted
to share so this is um it's a good book
it's elaine's scary's thinking and
emerge thinking in an emergency
um and i reread much of it this week and
i find the kinds of emergencies that she
is talking about thinking in
much more localized um than i was hoping
for things like well her first example
our first main example of four is for
instance
cpr and how cpr has spread throughout
the world and how individuals end up
knowing how to how to do it which is um
important but not exactly apropos for
right now
however
she says
see if i find this just two things early
on
um
all along the people of the united
states have had the legal procedures to
prevent
this from happening oh um exterminating
another population that is why didn't we
use them we still have those legal
procedures why don't we use them now
the existence of nuclear weapons
endangers all the populations of the
world they are truly what in earlier
centuries was meant by the legal
principle quad omnis tanget that which
touches all
that sentence has a second half
and i'm sure i'm butchering the latin
here quad omnis tangent ab omnibus
deciduter
that which touches all requires
everyone's agreement
so this is an important legal principle
that i had not seen in the in the latin
before anyway
um
and
one more point from elaine scary's book
is she's talking about uh
our toad's writing on thucydides and
says
um
that
i think this is our toe
understanding what the citizens were
saying is that the goal of the emergency
spectacle
is to bring about a genuine enslavement
of the attention
and
i don't know that we can
say that that is universally the goal
but that it certainly serves those who
would turn an emergency spectacle into
something for their own ends that once
you can grab
a person's a population's attention with
a spectacle that may or may not be an
emergency the likes of which you're
being told it is
then you can do a whole lot with that
individual or that population that you
could not previously do
and so in in service of that um the
first of the twelve books and you just
jump in whatever you want you sure you
don't even know the books that i'm no i
don't i'm here i'm i'm curious yeah um
the first i have them upside down for
some reason okay here we go
the first of the 12 books you stuck on
my scarf
speaking of attention is the world
beyond your head
on becoming an individual in the age of
distraction this is matthew crawford a
terrific author uh who i've mentioned uh
many times here before and uh in this
book he talks
he talks about
getting our attention back from those
forces that would have it that would
have it um as perhaps uh the most
salient and actionable thing that we can
do um to bring back a sense of coherence
yeah he's a lovely human being too and
um there's something about the
deliberate consciousness that is um
i think uh
very consistent with the way you and i
see things if you're living in a novel
era basically your conscious mind is the
the mechanism you need to navigate with
and um
anyway a lot of us don't and a lot of us
you know our conscious minds are
occupied with mundane stuff which also
happens to be novel but isn't isn't
worthy of them but
exactly
uh the second book on my list of 12
important books um is oliver sacks an
anthropologist on mars now this is um
he's unfortunately dead now a few years
um and this is one of his his early
books
oh actually it's not that early from
1995 maybe my favorite among his i've
read almost all of his work he was a
um
i want to say a neuroscientist
and also
effectively sort of a clinical
psychologist although i'm not sure
exactly i don't remember exactly how he
described himself but in this book he
takes on um basically he describes
seven of his patients um as effectively
case histories and you know what is what
has gone wrong in their brain such that
they are seeing the world in a totally
unusual way and in some cases what that
opens up for them and what doors it
closes down and so just
taken taken in through this
extraordinarily you know brilliant and
compassionate man's eyes to see to try
to see the world in a way that almost
none of us have ever seen it in seven
different ways um really can provide a
sense of
a sense of the other that so many people
are actually failing to try to do at the
moment i think sax is the doctor who is
depicted in the movie i think it's also
a book awakenings uh played by robin
williams so brilliantly in that in that
film uh where
uh sax
literally awakened a bunch of parent uh
of patients who had locked in syndrome
um and he used el dopa to uh to break
them out unfortunately only temporarily
but anyway it's it's the same sort of uh
approach where you know a doctor does
good doctoring where they experiment
till they get to something that
works for patients and anyway
i agree anthropologist on mars it's a
brilliant book as is i thought uh
manomist took his wife for a hat yes
yes absolutely
okay third uh and these you know these
are not ranked they're sort of ordered
ish um but these are this is not a rank
list weapons oh i took the cover off
that you can't weapons of mass
instruction by john taylor gatto uh he
this is
this
man also recently dead
was a
first class world-class educator
who spent i don't know 30 40 years
something teaching in the new york city
public schools won awards for for being
such an extraordinary teacher was not
simply
you know a good teacher on the page
students adored him and
and he was recognized as an excellent
teacher and then
at some point he
decided that it was necessary for him to
stand up against what he saw
as the denigration of education and
therefore of students
that is so widespread at this point in
what he correctly calls compulsory
schooling which is the model that we
live under so
also i have i have
learned from everything i've read of
gatosk but this weapons of mass
instruction is particularly particularly
impactful
four and again all of these i think have
something to teach us in the in the
current moment
um four
mother nature maternal instincts and how
they shape the human species now that's
a different subtitle than was originally
published this is sarah blaffer hardy
this is basically a book um that i used
to use as a way
to seminar on with my students as a way
to introduce
students to um evolutionary biology uh
with regard to humans uh you know we
would start with with dawkins the
selfish gene and then we would work
through this book and over several weeks
and
um
a she's she's brilliant and uh b she's a
great writer and a great storyteller and
it also does the at that point this was
written in the 90s and i was you know
teaching the um started teaching with
this in like 2003 or four
it was somewhat unusual in being um you
know being told often from the
perspective of what is you know what are
the females in the situation um you know
getting from this what's the angle as
opposed to you know the relatively male
biased
um ways that um that such stories such
scientific stories have been written in
the past um enough so that i actually
early on in teaching animal behavior had
a couple of students ask me why
evolutionary biology was so biased
towards females
which is a totally laughable proposition
but it made me sort of appreciate the
book even more and also appreciate my
own
biases like you know i didn't pick it
because because of all of that but i
thought oh then she has successfully
she successfully done
in this book you know what so many
people have successfully done before but
from the other perspective and it just
it reveals that um you can tell true
scientific stories and the stories that
you choose to tell are going to reflect
your biases but that shouldn't affect
what the stories actually are
yeah and it's a
really
there's no reason for the bias right the
bias is completely a historical artifact
i should also just point out that uh
sarah blaffer hearty
comes from the same evolutionary
tradition that we do she is a
a fellow student of bob trivers and so
uh
anyway if you
like our style of reasoning you're very
likely to like hers yeah if i remember
correctly she was an undergrad at
harvard when he was a graduate student
there so she was his student um earlier
like when he was writing the very
important papers he was writing and then
i would we were his
students later on when he was a
professor at uc santa cruz uh okay
number
five chandler burrs the emperor of scent
a true story of perfume and obsession
what like why why would that be
important this is um this is another
book that i used to teach with a lot and
so so did you
um you can see it you know very well
book darted as most of these are um
this book is again brilliantly written
but it also reveals the ways that modern
science fail us
and it tells the story of luca turin
who is an extraordinary scientist who
has
it seems like
figured out how smell works
and that seems like something that
probably we should have figured out a
long time ago but no there's a lot that
we don't yet know in science and he
seems to have figured it out
and uh he has not only not been
recognized for it but uh been actively
um you know shut out of many of the
conversations where he should have been
present in part because he and this is
this is too simple it's too simplistic
but in part because he's too much of a
generalist um because he does physics
and he does biology and he does
chemistry he does all of it and he can
talk across all of these boundaries and
frankly those who are specially trained
and are only specialists find that kind
of capacity
um
frankly very intimidating and
and they try to shut it down well i
would add something to that
the
problem i think is a generalist takes a
toolkit and walks into a puzzle and says
well
what makes sense here in light of what
the evidence is and that is very
different than the process of picking up
the school of thought that owns the
field right and so the school of thought
that owns the olfactory
perception field
is shapism which is the very logical
idea that we smell things based on the
fact that a molecule that has a
particular shape finds a receptor with
the inverse shape they bind it sends a
message to the brain it all makes
perfect sense right except that it
doesn't make sense at all because the
system is capable of smelling a
infinite diversity of things
instantaneously and ordinarily with
every other system in fact you have to
choose between these things you can
recognize an infinite diversity of
things the way our immune systems do but
it takes time to develop the immunity or
you can smell things instantaneously or
perceive things instantaneously but it's
a limited library so how do you get the
two happening simultaneously here this
is such an important point you know you
can have it all but it'll take time or
you can have a subset right now you
can't have both you can have both and so
anyway a generalist walks in and says
something about the story doesn't add up
whereas if you you know were schooled by
the experts what they've done is shown
you all of the wonderful evidence in the
direction of shapism and they haven't
shown you the evidence that tells them
that they don't know the whole story and
so anyway he um is effectively persona
non grata in the mainstream on the other
hand he's got a model that's a hell of a
lot more predictive than the model that
they've got although the caricature of
it you've got an oscilloscope in your
nose does sound laughable it sounds
laughable on the other hand you know
prediction is the coin of the realm so
anyway it's a wonderful book it does
show exactly how fields get stuck by a
school of thought
uh owning them it also will cause you to
give a damn about perfume and and smells
in a way that you never have before in
fact when i've taught from this book i
know you've had the same experience
students become so interested in
smelling things and then trying to
characterize them that they will go into
you know
burly dudes we'll go into perfume stores
and start smelling stuff to see if they
can can uh can figure it out anyway it
is a great book yeah it is and chandler
burr um who's written is is an
extraordinary writer as well i will say
i wish um actually i don't remember
exactly when this book was written i
think it had not been yet 2002. um i had
the lovely experience of spending a week
in egypt with my parents back in the mid
90s so before this book was written and
we spent a little bit of a little bit of
time in
some of those perfume stores that um
that in fact luca turin has spent time
in you know sourcing some of the um
really amazing fragrances and i wish i
could time i wish i could have those
experiences again right with this with
the knowledge in this book in my head oh
we should also say uh that luca turn is
a an extremely i don't even have
forgotten the name of the person who
specializes in scent production
and he's written
several world famous guides to perfumes
and we've actually read from a few from
from that once yeah as well they're
marvelous and they're especially good
when he dislikes a fragrance
when he pans the fragrance and he
explains you know
this powdery affair you know
yeah he and his
his partner whose name i've forgotten at
the moment but have written um a couple
of perfume guys that are exquisite and
you don't again you don't have to care
yeah about the the perfumes themselves
or have or know them at all or have you
know any
any familiarity with the history of
perfumery which you know neither of us
do but they're they're hilarious
um okay number six on this list of 12
important books is again i've taken off
the jacket um jerry muller is the
tyranny of metrics
um
this is um a short book really um and
this is relatively recent 2018.
um i read this
first as we were working on hunter
gatherer's guide the 21st century and it
fit as so many
you know we have talked about
concepts being obvious in retrospect
many evolutionary concepts being obvious
in retrospect which in fact we
considered as an alternate title for the
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century so much of what is true
um or is or is logically robust in
evolutionary biology once you hear it
it's actually hard to put yourself back
in the position of not knowing it it
feels so obvious things just fit into
place you know the epicycles vanish and
including darwinism itself including
darwinism itself exactly and so you know
you but you know but there is more to
know all right and so i think with
regard to darwinism you'll have for
instance a lot of people in biology who
aren't evolutionary biologists say well
yeah of course right of course evolution
that can be summed up in a paragraph
right um well and not not just that they
may be
like wondering what it is that we're
doing over here but they don't actually
they haven't actually tracked
the logical implications of what it is
into their own work
um
and
anyway i feel like this entire book
is it's it's again short but brilliantly
researched and he's got um he's got the
tyranny of metrics applied across
colleges schools medicine policing the
military business and
finance philanthropy and foreign aid and
it is
so important for an understanding of one
of the
one of the big
problems that we point out a lot
excuse me
is the reductionism uh that replaces a
holistic scientific thinking and which
many people who either wear the mantle
of science or think that they are
speaking on behalf of science
mistake metrics for understanding
and um that is really the the thesis of
the book but with a tremendous amount of
evidence and once you get it it'll make
you 19 smarter
okay six
six more
six more books
that's that's finite though you see i'm
i don't just yeah yeah i'm not you know
i could keep going but i'm not okay i've
only got a pile of
six more here okay number seven
probably saw this one coming bad pharma
how drug companies mislead doctors and
harm patients by ben goldacre
we've talked about this before a little
bit and it's um
it's just really important and frankly
the title says most of it except that
this is not a short book and it's
extraordinarily well researched and
there's a lot a lot here to learn from
with regard to what um
what's standard operating practice as of
2012 which is when the first edition of
this book came out uh was in the
relationship between uh pharmaceutical
companies and doctors and also research
both academic and industry
yeah i would recommend actually people
check out a ted talk by the author
called what doctors don't know about the
drugs they prescribed it is uh it's
quite good he's an excellent speaker as
well
um i do
wonder where he is
in the pandemic i find it shocking that
somebody who knows as much about um
about
pharma's corruption of our
of medicine
is missing how much corruption is
shaping our
our response to this and uh anyway i i
hope he arrives soon yeah
number eight on the list anatomy of an
epidemic
magic bullets psychiatric drugs and the
astonishing rise of mental illness in
america
by robert whittaker uh
again extraordinary
terrifying
uh
brilliantly researched
just one here's just here's just one
thing from it um
actually sure if this is going to show
because i've only got the hard copy here
um here we have
um
i've got a book started twice it's funny
um
long-term recovery rates for
schizophrenic patients uh
two-year follow-up through 15-year
follow-up um the y-axis is zero to fifty
percent uh and for those of you who
let's see if i can oh wait there there's
my camera um for those of you just
listening um and now i'm just going from
memory because i can't see the thing
anymore um basically those who are off
antipsychotics have a much higher rate
of recovery from schizophrenia than
those who are on antipsychotics
that the people who are
on antipsychotics
have a recovery rate in the 5 to 10
percent
range from schizophrenia and those who
are off antipsychotics have a recovery
rate uh in the
35 40 to 45 range um so that you know
that in a nutshell is the kind of um
result and then analysis that he's doing
in this book yeah it's terrifying i
would point out it uh
this stands to reason right
your your your brain and the mind
phenomenon that it creates are
a tool a means to an end and to the
extent that they are malfunctioning
that's bad for the creature and so
they're built to self-correct lots of
things about us are built to
self-correct and if your instinct is to
medicate something
right that that's your response and the
point is what you do is you remove the
ability for the system to detect what's
wrong and to repair and so
and something you didn't mention here
and we've talked about it before i think
on the podcast
is that in other parts of the world
people who have a schizophrenic break
often recover right they have one they
don't it's not they're schizophrenic
because they had an episode and it goes
away and so there's a question and any
time you see a pattern like that the
question is well what are we doing
that's messing that up
yeah right what we obviously that's
something that we should be seeking
might it might even if you knew why that
was distinct you might even be able to
eliminate the problem altogether and in
fact we propose something in our book uh
let's not go into it now but but anyway
there may well it's it's clearly at
least largely a novelty problem and um
that means the solution at least for
people who haven't yet come down with it
is likely recognizing what the novel
influence is and corralling it
yeah the way you said that
made me think you know all this language
policing that is happening especially in
the woke world
around you know what it is that you call
people and you know you can't say a fat
person you have to say a person of
fatness
i don't think that's the one not a
person of hope you know actually like a
person of size like
believe me there are stupid ways that
you're supposed to say it and you're not
supposed to oh i know they're stupid
you're not supposed to adjectivize right
and you know like you know black person
fat person gay person right like this is
actually i'm not sure we're ever told
not to do this with the lgbtq thing
which is you know always interesting the
inconsistencies in the
in the policing and the you know the
framework that we're supposed to be
adopting but um
there is
as with so many of these things at base
something real
to talk about and something real to
consider
that you know if
if in the rest of the world without our
modern pharmaceutical
interventions around at least mental
illness like schizophrenia
people aren't schizophrenic for life
they tend to have a schizophrenic
episode
then presumably people aren't understood
as schizophrenics you know 10 years
after that one episode that they had
and so
um
training ourselves to understand these
things that we are currently doing or
experiencing or are happening to us and
therefore feel like the entirety of our
experience as temporary things that are
in a way you know passing through us and
we're passing through the time period
where they are us
uh can be a way to escape from what
seems like the permanence of you know
whatever hell you may think you're
experiencing at the moment yeah right
like i'm you know i am a depressed
person
you're experiencing a depressive episode
right now and um you know let's get you
out of that but uh but you know this
this too shall pass yeah unless unless
you rush to medicate it so the system
does not have a calibration precisely to
get you out yeah actually that that's
thank you because that's that's actually
where i was going i think the the
tyranny of metrics and the you know then
the
um
perverse incentives of the companies
that make money from keeping people
medicated for life
creates a world in which it is all too
easy to see ourselves as patients as
consumers as schizophrenics or
depressives or you know whatever it is
that your diagnosis is and you know
you're not your diagnosis you're many
many more things than that yeah and you
shouldn't identify as a consumer for
sure there's something um
you know obviously there are good
doctors out there
um but there's something about
maybe it is even the reward structure
for a doctor where when they
are able to give you something they're
able to identify the condition and give
you something that gives you relief or
causes the problem to go away you're
right they've done their job whereas you
know let's compare you know okay they
give you a drug that
solves some problem you've got right
that seems that's a very aggressive
intervention whereas
advising you that you're probably
vitamin d deficient during the winter
and should probably supplement you'll
never know the things that you've been
saved from right because you just simply
won't come down with them and so it
doesn't strike you oh my god that
doctor's great he saved me you know
three colds this winter yeah right you
don't feel that it's not the same thing
and so you know if you think about
medicine
as some kind of analog for our online
environment where you're induced to do
things by a dopamine reward
doctors are also apes that are driven by
dopamine rewards and their the rewards
are not well structured to result in the
best medical treatment which is i'm sure
one contributor to the reason that
there's so much bad medicine yes oh
that's that's brilliant yes
okay uh two books of a slightly
different sort uh both of which we've
talked about on here again i've taken
off the book jacket but live not by lies
by rod drear which we spoke we spent a
whole almost an entire episode on a
while back
the subtitle is a manual for christian
dissidents
and
this is written just in 2020 it came out
i think last summer which is when we
talked about it and it really describes
again somewhat terrifyingly
and in
in terrific detail with stories from uh
from people who have lived through
um
totalitarian regimes and who actually do
this this is one of the few places where
i at least have seen the description of
what it feels like as it comes on
um so you know this this is a very
important book and it's of course uh
named for
the
social needs an essay of the same name
which is also terrific and highly
recommended and findable online so live
not by lies sultan needs an essay
originally from
i guess mid 20th century um and then rod
drear's book in 2020 of the same name
yeah it is
uh it's obviously a moment that we
should be reading the five or six
maybe it's 10 or 12 good things on this
topic because obviously most people are
missing what's taking place right in
front of them and we're having stupid
arguments about whether it's even
happening right
and i you know i didn't put on the book
um
[Music]
i just i haven't reread actually in 1984
and brave new world
and catch 22
all of which we've talked about here but
i haven't reread them recently enough to
to to to put them here um or actually
the gulag the gulag archipelago by
social nissan which i read my first
quarter in college
um i think
think does this you know brilliantly as
well but you know there there's a lot
not on this list right um
all right however this is this is one
that is erikoff or the true believer um
thoughts on the nature of mass movements
um so
just in in light of conversations about
mass formation uh and such eric hoffer
this is from mid mid 20th century 1951
does a um
does a fantastic job of describing
what
it looks like from the outside and to
some degree on the inside so here are
just two very brief quotes from hoffer
again written
over half a century ago
once come the fanatics he asks
mostly from the ranks of the
non-creative men of words
the most significant division between
men of words is between those who can
find fulfillment and creative work and
those who cannot
i'll read just two more sentences here
uh the creative man of words no matter
how bitterly he may criticize and deride
the existing order is actually attached
to the present his passion is to reform
and not to destroy
so
he finds
and i think i think he's right um that
so much and again you know he's talking
about fanatics in the mid 20th century
um are people who are
you know literate people of letters
people in the so-called intellectual
class the lettered class
perhaps the elite you might call them
but who don't actually have much
original to offer and so they become
more easily
attracted to and perhaps indebted to
fanaticism well it's actually a
uh
a
corollary of what you and i talk about
with respect to the importance of
education including
interaction with physical systems
in that you can't fool that are not
socially mediated
um and so we do find all sorts of people
who are very learned in some way some
book way but it is not tested against
reality these people can become
extremely enamored of ideas that are
terrible because they don't spot why
they're terrible and i will say i think
the inverse is true that in general
if you meet somebody you know
there are people who work with their
hands badly but they don't tend to stick
with it
people who have a tradition of working
with their hands tend to be very down to
earth because the thing is if you're not
down to earth and you're doing some
physical thing then you're constantly
frustrated because it doesn't work right
so you have to sort of accept you know
its authority you have to accept the
authority of the physical world over
whatever you're trying to do and that
i wonder if it doesn't just make you a
better less dangerous human being that's
fascinating i've never thought
to frame it in those terms that you just
did you have to respect the authority of
the thing that you are working with the
physical system that is giving you
feedback
and um
and that helps you learn not to follow
false authority actually yeah because
you recognize
uh you you come to understand what real
authority is in the form of you know
gravity or
you know forces from a saw or uh the you
know chemical leveling agents in a cake
uh yeah and
and there's just no negotiating with
them yeah actually i had an interesting
one yesterday i have first in my
lifetime uh physical experience that
taught me what i was misunderstanding
um we have this power washer and uh toby
had used it to to power wash something
for us toby he was 15. he's 15.
um
and he had put the hose on it the
pressure side hose right and
i went to take it off to put the thing
away and i could not dislodge the thing
i got to the point of using wrenches i
still couldn't just nor could he right
right nobody could anyone in the family
and so i mean i didn't think he was
especially likely to have put it on that
i mean you know if he put it on too
tight right and nobody could get it off
by hand surely a wrench would do it but
no this thing was on there like nothing
i've ever
and it turned out when i finally
dislodged it that it the thing was still
pressurized
that the hose was still pressurized and
full of water so it was pushing the
threads against each other in such a way
that they were basically
probably they had galled together
right
um yeah that's the term i don't i
actually don't recognize that term um
gold is what you said yeah i i reserve
the right to discover five minutes after
the podcast is over that i've forgotten
the right term but i believe galling
when you take two like let's say you
have a nut and a bolt of the same metal
right and you screw them together very
tightly well if you screw them together
and they're appropriate for each other
they've got the right threads correct
threads but if you screw them together
really tightly what happens is the two
objects are put so close together that
some of the molecules sort of forget
which whether they're
nut or bolt and so basically they weld
right and so it's very hard to break
them free um and there are various
things you can do you can put you know a
thin film of something in there grease
or whatever but
um
but anyway this
the pressure in this system made what
went on by hand impossible to remove by
wrench and he and i did get our
comeuppance because we're standing
rather too close to the point you
finally got it free
yeah it was really something
like it was already pouring outside
somewhat damp i learned we all survived
yes we sure did yeah yeah
um
okay number 11 on this book um and there
are some other things we want to talk
about today but this is of course taking
a while um is something probably no
one's going to come be expecting is
tom wolf's the right stuff
uh this is uh
this
i
this is just such a terrific book
to explore what is possible and what is
you know what
people who
have something they want to accomplish
in the world and are
driven to do it no matter what some
other people think the value is
can do and it's just it's a it's a
it's of course brilliantly written um
again tom wolf recently died as well i
think did he oh god maybe yeah maybe he
didn't okay i'll figure that out um
tom please take care of yourself if
you're still alive
well i don't know i'm trying to wish him
well but i'm not absolutely certain i
might have missed you know the news that
he's gone but i don't know that he's
gone zach if you have the ability to
figure out um that that would be
fabulous okay
um but and actually if you can get them
on the phone just put them through yeah
yeah terrific
uh
i don't have much more to say about this
but when i s but when my eyes fell onto
this on my shelf i thought this belongs
on a list of important books that are
relevant for the moment to give people
hope
actually about what what we can be what
what extraordinary things people can
do he's no longer alive yeah all right
we didn't do that did we zach
okay
um and then finally uh the 12th book on
this list of important books is
sebastian younger's tribe on homecoming
and belonging a book that i've read from
before
utterly
brilliant and short i was going to say
utterly short which is not that short
doesn't really
go with utterly but i have a very short
excerpt to read from this
contempt is often used
contempt is often directed to people who
have been excluded from a group are
declared unworthy of its benefits
contempt is often used by governments to
provide rhetorical cover for torture or
abuse
contempt is one of four behaviors that
statistically can predict divorce in
married couples people who speak with
contempt for one another will probably
not remain united for long
the most alarming rhetoric comes out of
the dispute between liberals and
conservatives and it's a dangerous waste
of time because they're both right
the perennial conservative concern about
high taxes supporting a non-working
underclass has entirely legitimate roots
in our evolutionary past and shouldn't
be dismissed out of hand
early hominids lived a precarious
existence where freeloaders were a
direct threat to survival and so they
developed an exceedingly acute sense of
whether they were being taken advantage
of by members of their own group
but by the same token one of the
hallmarks of early human society was the
emergence of a culture of compassion
that cared for the ill the elderly the
wounded and the unlucky
in today's terms that is a common
liberal concern that also has to be
taken into account
those two driving forces have coexisted
for hundreds of thousands of years in
human society and have been duly
codified in this country as a two-party
political system
the eternal argument over so-called
entitlement programs and more broadly
over liberal and conservative thought
will never be resolved because each side
represents an ancient and absolutely
essential component of our evolutionary
past
so how do you unify a secure wealthy
country that is sunk into a zero-sum
political game with itself
how do you make veterans feel that they
are returning to
a cohesive society that was worth
fighting for in the first place
i put that question to rachel yehuda of
mount sinai hospital in new york city
yehuda has seen up close the effect of
such anti-social divisions on
traumatized vets
quote if you want to make a society work
then you don't keep underscoring the
places where you're different you
underscore your shared humanity she told
me
i'm appalled by how much people focus on
differences
why are you focusing on how different
you are from one another and not on the
things that unite us
hell yeah hell yeah that's that's
a square on and i would just say the
other thing is don't let people
emphasize your differences because
that's what's happening there's a reason
that we are
we are divided at the razor's edge and
we now have routine photo finish
elections and that is not about some
organic phenomenon that is about
our division being necessary to whatever
it is that is governing us continuing to
do what it does without having to pay
too much attention to what we need or
want exactly right and um
to the degree that younger has
accurately described um some of the
fundamental positions of liberals versus
conservatives and i think he has
so much of what the democrats and
republicans currently represent has very
little to do with those things um and
you know we we as
uh
having been lifelong democrats are more
attuned to the changes in the democratic
party but
certainly it has strayed very very very
far
from its
traditional
its historic values
well i would say i mean you know it's
interesting because we spend so much
time now uh interacting with honorable
conservatives that i have to go back and
look at what i used to think about
republicans and say did i have it right
and have things changed did i have it
wrong and it's a mixture but
um
but i have thought but also with regard
to the democratic party itself
right so the democratic so it used to be
a division between
more or less
management and labor right and the
democrats represented labor and with
clinton
they
became direct competitors with the
republicans and they competed over
management and they abandoned labor yeah
and so the point is in my opinion the
republican party
was more corrupt because it was more
closely aligned with capital not that
the unions weren't corrupt because they
were but
um but nonetheless it
because it was the you know the c-suite
the corruption was direct and then the
democrats took over
the model and they basically
set up their own racket and now i think
in some ways maybe in many ways they
have exceeded the republicans in their
corruption
and
um so you know i do have to sort of go
back decades and think actually you know
democrats have not been very good at
representing labor in a very very long
time but labor is at least a natural
entity that does encompass most of us
yes and um it's been a long time since
i've seen the democratic party give
any thought to those people yes actually
this um this is a good segue if if if we
might uh into
this
oh
hold on
no i'm i'm looking for the piece
um published in the hill this week you
can show me
show my screen here zach
hat tip to tim poole who tweeted this
the headline is biden is delivering the
fastest economic recovery in history why
hasn't anyone noticed
and
it proceeds with a whole bunch here you
can give my screen back here
a whole bunch of claims
that seem suspect although i didn't go
through and try to track them down
and certainly uh
certainly the idea that we are living
through the best time in economic
history in the united states would would
seem to be false on its face in a lot of
regards but just take for a moment
assume for a moment the headline
um
is accurate that we accept the premise
of the piece and the numbers therein
like i said i don't and i don't i don't
accept the premise and i don't accept
the numbers but okay we are led to this
remarkable statement in the inside of
this article quote democrats biggest
problem a conservative media machine
pumping out economic disinformation on a
24 7 production schedule
so if the democrats really believe now
this is not the democrats saying this
but this is you know the hill reporting
on what they see as the democrats uh
biggest problem
if they really believe that their
biggest problem is the conservative
media machine it's entirely outside of
them
this is like this is victim culture at
the political level this is like oh woe
is me everyone does this stuff to me if
only you guys would leave me alone then
i could do the amazing honorable stuff
that i've always been trying to do like
if the dnc truly believes their biggest
problem is external to them then then it
will fail that it is doomed i was going
to say we are doomed but no it is doomed
uh because that's
that's hogwash
yeah boy i love the idea that the dnc
might be doomed that would be marvelous
well i mean it's also oh man
the democrats current mode of
like
propaganda and censorship and frankly
taking on the mantle of enlightenment
values in this caricaturey way like like
i am science right and then making
pronouncements that are unscientific and
unverifiable and unfalsifiable too
um
i think that's that thing that i just
said the the censorship and the you know
abandonment and the transformation of
enlightenment values to serve their own
petty ends or non-petty ends um like
that's their biggest problem
or there's a bunch of other things
beyond the external media
i mean and and also how much of the
media
are
is or is being fed by what the dnc wants
right i mean no it's preposterous right
you know the conservative media machine
is arguably
fox right right um
but then there is a much bigger machine
that leans in the other direction so
what the hell right fox you know me you
know a few newspapers i guess but let's
see
like
msnbc
um
i want to say the cdc that's
cnn you know basically all the other
networks uh npr new york times
wapo you know
almost everything as as we know this
this box let's put it this way this bias
in the other direction then is being
claimed as the democrats biggest problem
in order for that to be an explanation
it would have to be the larger force and
given that the conservative media
machine is the smaller force
that's not a very good explanation yeah
it's really not but i mean i think we
should come to expect not very good
explanations from the democrats at this
point
um
yeah so you know i guess given that this
feels very much to me like the sort of
victim culture that is uh that has been
very much the rage on college campuses
of uh you know don't put anything in
front of me that i might be alarmed by
that i might have my feelings hurt uh
anything that goes wrong is about me
having been victimized as opposed you
know i never should you know take any
control of my own life i would say um
two individuals who actually buy this
including the dnc perhaps um take some
responsibility for your damn self get a
grip like
um wake the [ __ ] up
and
do some things that are actually good
for the people in the country and stop
lying to us
that that's a start maybe one of your
biggest problems is that you're lying to
us too much and are you know are the
republicans also lying to us i'm sure of
course like that's what politicians do
but it seems to have become one of the
planks the platform i don't know i
i don't think
the point is
even to expect them to lie to us less or
do something good is to misunderstand
what they do the business model they're
not supposed to have a business model
but they do have a business model and it
has to do with their real constituents
which are not the people
right so i don't even know
i don't know what the point of you know
it's like going to criminals and saying
less crime you want us not to go after
you do less crime and it's like no
criminals well i guess i'm there are
still some number of people and i have
no idea
what fraction of
voters in this country
might believe that the the democrats
biggest problem is
the republican media machine
and
um i will say that again you know as i
mentioned last week i i walk around i
end up having you know short
conversations with strangers and i
overhear conversations um some of whom
are among people who i then interact
with and some of whom aren't
and um yeah and this is in this is in
deep blue portland this is this is in a
city that routinely votes you know very
very very very blue
and um you know i overheard another
conversation a little bit like the one i
required last week this this one between
two
elderly women actually you know
white-haired women at a coffee shop
who said um
bob was hospitalized after getting his
booster
and then they said look around they got
very very quiet and then the next thing
i heard was
i'm not sure if i should cancel my
appointment
i just don't think they're telling us
the truth
this is in deep blue portland among
older women who are more likely than
any other demographic by age or sex to
to listen to the authorities and to say
okay you said i should i should i will
um you know even
even in that group we are seeing people
experience with their own
you know in their own families and
friend groups actually
what i know is not a match for what i'm
being told and also i've had
four conversations in this last week in
which people without my prompting said
what we need is leadership
and i'm hearing this with regard to
again in deep blue portland at the city
level at the state level at the federal
level
all of which in oregon are currently um
blue leaders right and so there are a
whole lot of people who are i think you
know to to agree with you we're saying
you know
why why frankly are we continuing to
talk to the same people who continue to
do the same thing
uh we need something different
well in fact they are
handing the allegiance of the people to
the republicans
yes they're handing it to them because
in some sense the democratic party has
started doing all kinds of things for
reasons that serve constituents that we
barely know yes
and all the republicans have to do in
order to actually be preferred is block
terrible democratic ideas and
this
it doesn't have to be this way the fact
is there's a mystery just as there is a
mystery why it is
no colleges and universities that are
resisting wokeness when obviously a huge
number of people want one why they're
um you know
why there aren't social media platforms
uh that are wildly popular that you know
don't censor all of these things
um in the same sense
you a party that actually served the
interests of the people would be wildly
popular
right for obvious reasons and yet the
point is we're forced to choose between
corporatist parties and
that tells you what the game is
it does
and
um
yes it does
right well
yeah um
so zack says we're an hour i saw us
start at um
at 8 30 uh when we're through with the
ad so we've got another 10 minutes or so
there is at least one more thing that i
want to talk about here i don't know
where you might want to go
um
we will
move from that ah no
i've lost it here we go
last week you
talked a little bit about omicron the
new variant uh that we are all supposed
to be quite terrified of
uh there is um
we've been involved in some
conversations about what what it is what
it means what um what it actually
actually we've talked about for the last
two weeks i guess
and it's hard to to find
real data right it's hard to find actual
information
and the oregon health authority which i
get missibs from as i have mentioned
several times on this show
um came to the [ __ ] rescue this week
awesome with everything you ever wanted
to know about the omicron variant so i'm
going to put this up um i'm going to
have you not quite yet sec but i'm going
to have you put it up on my screen just
briefly
and then take it down while i read to
you guys what i learned from the oregon
health authority this week about omicron
so here it is omicron what we know about
this new variant
all right um
number so as i just
i don't want you guys getting ahead of
me um
it's five it's five points
color-coded i don't know what the colors
mean though so maybe it's not
color-coded five points omicron what we
know about this new variant i was so
eager to hear with the oregon health
authority oh totally i mean what do the
data say what do the data say one
viruses like sars cov2 the virus that
causes cova-19 mutate or change
constantly
two
all over the world
scientists are studying the omicron
variant
three
we know how to protect ourselves and
others against infection get it
vaccinated if you're eligible a booster
wear mask in indoor public settings or
outdoor credit settings keep physical
distance and wash hands frequently
four
oregon health authority is monitoring
omicron
closely
and five and you can put my screen up
now if you like zack as we learn more we
will share information on how you can
best protect yourself and keep your
loved ones and your community safe
i mean among other things the oregon
health authority has revealed that they
in fact know nothing about omicron
and have nothing to share and really
shouldn't put this into their missive
because they have just further reduced
the confidence that they
know anything and have anything to offer
this may be i mean it's it's a it's a
low bar at this point like for worst
so i didn't i'm not sure i haven't
reversed a sign there but like could
this be the worst messaging we've seen
so far at least it's not it's not
misinformation it's just no information
no information
completely empty well it reminds me of
the uh i was just trying to find it but
the
terror threat level color coding system
which was a very useful system you'll
recall for avoiding since like after 9
11 yeah after after 9 11 the the
government uh actually in conjunction
with the red cross
put together a very informative resource
about how you should respond to the
different terror
threat levels is this going to be at the
level of like duck and cover
well it was as i recall it um
you know you had green through
red and green was
there's no threat of terrorism which i
guess would be equivalent to the
extinction of humanity which would be
the end of the threat of terrorism i
mean you've seen like squirrels going
after each other i feel like squirrel
terrorism is a possibility this world
terror is a thing i don't know about
okay okay you don't think it's organized
right no no i okay but in any case green
is an unattainable goal green is an
unattainable goal so you sort of start
at yellow and yellow is like well
terrorism is possible today
and uh you know
yellow had it had some some
pretty useful stuff in it you know you
should probably
have a plan and you might want some
supplies because
things like that right and so okay
that's good i think a plan
oh and i think you were supposed to
listen to authorities if they provided
information on what you should do right
um and then every level on top of that
basically just revisited the things they
had already told you you need to do
um but with like greater urgency like
definitely listen to authorities and
things like that
make sure those supplies are still great
yeah check your supply exactly so it was
just empty there was nothing there it
was just completely emotional
manipulation by color coding right no
it's not a green day i mean i wonder
that it speaks a little bit to this you
know the tyranny of metrics thing you
know there's it except in that case
like the color coding there's like an
implied
numeric there's an implied ranking right
so there is this
you know implication of quantitative
thinking that has gone into it and
they're just not bothering us with the
numbers don't worry about that but you
know they in all you have to do is like
plug in
to we've used numbers
and you get people to go along with it
yeah no well but i i think the point
really is
you're you're not
you know what it is it's um
it's public policy where they forgot to
replace the
what is it laura mipsum
[Laughter]
you know
somebody put together all right you know
what we really need we need a you know
like a five points what we know about
omicron right and somebody
all over the world scientists are
studying right which is literally the
only like that's actually the most
that's two of them actually mentioned
omicron at all the other one being
oregon health authority is monitoring
omicron but you can imagine right if you
knew that there was a you know five
points you need to have about omicron
and you just wanted to like rough some
stuff in and then you're going to come
back later and then you got distracted
and then somebody cuts it out right
exactly it would be that and you know
that was the terror threat level in
which case we actually i believe
discovered i mean the whole reason that
it's not like terrorism has gone
anywhere when's the last time you saw a
color code for where we are at threat
level right they got rid of it because
you know everybody sort of understood it
was a political manipulation tool
designed to just sort of you know you
know amp your amygdala or whatever right
um and so okay how many times are we
gonna fall for this crap right the
pretense that there's information in
there about omicron yep
i mean even if it was five questions
here are five things to watch out for
things we'd like to know about omicron
right
you know
how you know how virulent is it that's a
very important question because how do
you know this could be a great thing
right if it's if it's very mild
symptom-wise and produces lifelong
immunity it could save us from this
vaccine madness and the insanity of our
public health response as we said
several weeks ago
does overcrowd like delta before it
seemed to evade the vaccines hmm
interesting question right so you could
you could say here some things to watch
out for but you can't say here here are
the things you need to know and then not
say anything
yeah yeah knowing exactly that and
man there was something
there was something related to that but
um
maybe that's it there's
we knew we had to be pretty brief today
and then we had some technical problems
so um
maybe
maybe we're going to do a short show
this week we're going to take as brief a
break as possible and come back with q a
we're going to start with a discord
question and then answer your questions
when we come back anything else to say
before we before we sign off well i
think i want to add a couple things to
the sign off um just based on where we
seem to be in history
um
so julian assange lost his uh battle
against extradition that's not to say
that it's the last round there's an
appeal that he has available to him i
believe but nonetheless this is
um this has gone on
far too long he's clearly a political
prisoner and
i don't expect
the biden administration to even
consider pardoning him no matter how
right a thing it would be
to do or to stop pursuing anything
but i would say
uh
free assange
bring snowden home
and stand up
these these mandates are immoral the
orders are immoral and we know what to
do standing up is what we are obligated
to do and so for for the moment those
three things
free assange bring snowden home
and uh stand up and stand up and um
in the meantime
be good to the ones you love and eat
good food and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]
you